quoi
[Musique]
donc
étranger
[Musique]
ces nouvelles variantes de virus, ils continuent d'
apparaître tous les deux jours et il est très
difficile de suivre ces euh
ces verrouillages et ces nouvelles
restrictions et
je ne '  Je ne sais pas vraiment ce que je ressens à
ce sujet parce que ça
devient un peu trop à ce
stade, moi-même, vous savez que
je ne
fais plus vraiment attention aux
nouvelles, je sens que c'est le bon  chose
donc je pense que parfois auparavant nous avons
été un peu en retard et apporté des
plaisirs et cela signifie que nous avons eu
beaucoup plus de temps avec des verrouillages plus longs
et je donc je préfère que nous soyons prudents
maintenant nous pouvons ouvrir  encore
[Musique]